hey guys i am just mcdonald it is the
19th of motti you're tuned in to guess
what news and we got plenty of stories
today so we better get into it first up
EA is in for a chance to take out worst
company in America again the publisher
is up against a number of other
companies who've managed to piss off
consumers this year in a poll annually
run by The Consumerist in the first
round EA is pitted up against time
warner cable and they'll need to get a
bigger section of the firt to pass on to
the next stage and potentially earn
themselves the worst company title for
the third year running next up is your
quick batch of titanfall news and the
360 version of the game is getting too
late again EA has confirmed an extra two
weeks worth of delay is hitting the game
and so now it'll launch on april eighth
in the US with a european release on the
11th hopefully the exact Patrick
Sutherland has said that the game is
fantastic but there's some things that
could do with improving so they're going
to give the developer Blue Point a
little more time do you see another
delay in titanfall on 360 s future or
not let me know and rounding off
everything you need to know about
titanfall EA may have secured the rights
to the sequel Pattonville to was
originally contingent on the performance
of the first game but given it seems to
have gone fairly well EA have decided to
officially get it in the bag according
to a reputable source EA has said they
don't comment on speculation but knowing
EA and knowing titanfall it's not that
much of a leap to assume that this may
well be exactly how it's going down last
off the mark today PlayStation have
kitted up and revealed their virtual
reality initiative ironically just days
after we were getting teased about
Microsoft revealing their own the
initiative called project Morpheus is a
head-mounted display complete with 1080p
and a 90 + degree field of view among
other steps that you should check out in
our new story on gamespot it's certainly
not the final prototype as stressed by
Sony but the publisher is adamant that
virtual reality will be the future of
gaming since as claimed by Sony
president Shuhei Yoshida nothing
elevates the level of
motion better than dr on display at GDC
the vr is currently running a reworking
of square enix's feast as well as Eve
Valkyrie and two other games called the
deep and the castle let me know whether
you reckon you would get into virtual
reality gaming and if you think it's the
future of gaming either in the comment
section down below or you can do so on
my Twitter where I'm at just McDonald
that is it for me today but be sure to
join me again for more news tomorrow and
I'll catch you later